le visage d'un rappeur devenu symbole de
liberté artistique et barricadé dans une
université et départ des dizaines de
partisans
[Applaudissements]
puis finalement arrêté et incarcéré
pablo race elle condamnée à neuf mois de
prison pour apologie du terrorisme et
injures envers la monarchie et les
institutions espagnoles condamnation
acté en mai dernier le rappeur avait
jusqu'au vendredi 12 février pour se
rendre en ce moment il me reste quelques
heures avant la date limite pour entrer
volontairement en prison pour avoir fait
des chansons écrit des tweets dénonçant
la monarchie la brutalité policière et
pour avoir montré ma solidarité avec les
prisonniers politiques de l'état
espagnol
je ne vais pas me présenter
volontairement prison car face à une
sentence aussi injuste ce serait une
humiliation indigne alors ils vont
devoir venir me kidnapper littéralement
pour mme emprisonné quelques heures
après son arrestation mardi environ 1700
manifestants se sont rassemblés dans les
rues de barcelone et d'autres villes de
catalogne
manifestations et confrontations avec
les forces de l'ordre
[Applaudissements]
des forces de l'ordre qualifiés
notamment je cite de mercenaires de
merde par le rappeur catalan dans une
série de tweets entre 2014 et 2016
une liberté d'expression défendu dans
une tribune par 200 artistes
hispanophone comme l'acteur javier
bardem est le réalisateur pedro
almodovar l'état espagnol est arrivé en
tête de liste des pays qui ont réprimé
le plus d'artistes pour le contenu de
leurs chansons maintenant avec
l'emprisonnement de pablo hazell l'état
espagnol se met au même niveau que des
pays comme la turquie ou le maroc près
du douar parlement de la culture
l'opposition de droite ou encore par
podemos l'un des partis au pouvoir le
gouvernement socialiste travaille ainsi
à la révision du code pénal et enel
padawan dans le cadre particulièrement
large et protéger des réflexions
artistiques culturels intellectuels dans
ce que nous appelons la liberté
d'expression il doit y avoir un éventail
de compréhension et de tolérance propres
à une démocratie absolument muant comme
la nôtre où la démocratie sans
mentionner pablo cassel le ministère de
la justice a annoncé une future réforme
dans laquelle les excès verbaux commis
dans le cadre de manifestations
artistiques culturelles ou
intellectuelles ne seront pas menacés
par une peine de prison